[Music]
FEMA is a small town in Julian but it's
linked to some pretty big names
especially Goethe and Schiller
but the poets aren't the reason for my
journey today it's the Bauhaus era that
started 100 years ago vitae koco's
Vasily Kandinsky poetry and many more in
1919 they were founding figures of the
Bauhaus movement vemma fine art design
and architecture Bauhaus became a
pioneer of modernity first in vemma then
in Dessau and berlin next year is the
anniversary 100 years Bauhaus but I'll
take a look at vemma today my first stop
in bimah is the Bauhaus University it
was designed by the architect Henry van
der veda with bright studios and curved
lines here vitae copias found at the
Bauhaus in 1919 a school of art and
design that would revolutionize the
shapes and colors of the 20th century
[Music]
no architect Tomas Apple takes me on a
tour here we have a stairwell that Van
de Velde designed with its elliptical
curves it's a very popular photographic
subject people who come here immediately
take a picture the reputation of the
Bauhaus attracted top names like clay
Kandinsky and finding a architect Walter
Gropius spent years developing the
artists network after World War one girl
who's picked up these contacts he'd made
he came here in 1919 and said I want to
do something completely new not just
architecture and not just applied arts I
want to found the Bauhaus artists
artisans and architects should be
trained together today about four
thousand aspiring architects and civil
engineers study at the University back
in the day there were just 150 masters
and students a small but dedicated
community fury of the work of habit
buyer who studied at the Bauhaus
he designed these works for the Bauhaus
exhibition in 1923 what's special is
that he worked in Kandinsky's class
where red squares and yellow triangles
were a theme combining basic shape with
the basic color when former Kuhn Farber
[Music]
now the highlight of the tour the study
of fighter group use sharp lines
straightforward and functional that was
the new Bauhaus style shoes off because
as an exception we're allowed to enter
the sanctuary well does this is the
original gopis room this is the original
directors room designed by Vata Gropius
for the 1923 Bauhaus exhibition the
exhibition aim to show the movements
achievements and explain it to say to
people in Vemma during it
this is our idea and this is what we're
working on that's this wound on table
even beyond definitely a nice sit-down
would it be globulus the others can but
you may no one's watching he is awesome
so this is where he said making
comfortable furniture wasn't that
important to him right because I have to
say this isn't a cozy chair this desk
chair has been reconstructed from
sketches and drawings there's no photo
of it it's not recorded Gropius actually
sat on a chair by decline at this desk
and later there so there was a steel
tube chair by masa
prior that he used at his desk this one
here is very theoretical it suits the
concept of this room when you look at
the surrounding edge this all-round
border low from the can disease you blow
from the lies
[Music]
traces of the Bauhaus are hard to find
at Vemma but they exist for example the
National Theatre the Constitution of the
vemma Republic was passed here in 1919
there is a plaque to commemorate it
[Music]
and who made it vitae corpus
[Music]
we continue to the historic cemetery
like a bolt of lightning
this monument shoots out of the ground
vitae copias build it on behalf of the
unions to commemorate the victims of the
political turmoil of 1920 the Nazis
destroyed the sculpture but it was later
rebuilt slightly modified
this is park under in where you'll find
the temple Heron house a neo-gothic
building where Bauhaus master johannes
itten had his painting studio it was
formed during world war ii and has
sensed it as a ruin in the park
[Music]
and finally the house I'm hon it's the
very first building built by the Bauhaus
in 1923 we can't visit at the moment
because it's been prepared for the
powers anniversary in 2019 this building
site is where the new Bauhaus museum
will stand the future director will he
keep askin takes me to have a look is
the building also Bauhaus style no it's
not Bauhaus style it's contemporary and
was designed by Berlin architect Haneda
but it is a cube and that immediately
makes you think of the Bauhaus with flat
roofs and things like that
it has connections to the Bauhaus Hika
Haneda is a real fan of nice photo and
her architecture can't hide that toward
a need for homely human the museum will
open in April 2000 nineteen for the
100th anniversary of Bauhaus it takes a
lot of imagination to picture the bright
showrooms that will be here for the
first time there will be enough space to
present the treasures of the vemma
Bauhaus collection to a white audience
are there any highlights
[Music]
if if Natalie highlights of course there
are highlights we know that many
visitors are especially interested in
Bauhaus artists we have outstanding
paintings by Lionel finding up a
wonderful painting by clay they'll be
exhibited down here in this area for now
the treasures are kept away from the
public safely guarded in a warehouse but
I can already admire some of the objects
but why do you need loves to handle the
lamp sometimes longer first yeah this is
ina lamp of fun once in this lamp so
it's back to 1924 it's my very own
bargain friend although it might look
quite robust it was made by hand and you
can also see that up here the glass has
a crack although there are reproductions
of the lamp on sale in every design shop
these first prototypes are very fragile
these figures look a bit more robust
doesn't handful
these are puppets by a barrage common he
visited a woodturners workshop here in
Vemma and was inspired to create these
completely new kinds of figures cans my
article think Mugen could fix it so what
are they for
it's a puppet so you put it on your hand
and do a show for kids good now exactly
the idea was to play with all four
children
my last stop in Vemma is the inch Liston
in this restaurant people from the
Bauhaus had wild parties students and
masters together and there were
legendary costume parties the Bauhaus
students could eat in the restaurant for
relatively little money and they love to
come here even though the decor is
anything but Bauhaus 100 years of
Bauhaus 2019 is its anniversary work is
being carried out everywhere to get
things ready I was surprised how many
traces I found anyway if you're also
interested in the early years of the
Bauhaus you should visit vemma next year
now it's time for me to check out the
local cuisine in the interested bye bye
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]